et on ce mardi 10 mai jour nationale de
commémoration de l'abolition de
l'esclavagé se termine la semaine pour
la mémoire de l'esclavagé à saint
quentin en yvelines le collectif en
charge de l'événement organisé cet après
midi à l'espace albert camus d'avoir pas
une exposition dédiée aux chants danses
et rythmes noirs au temps de l esclavage
camille lambert pour ce reportage regard
des
blues boca et samba trois genres
musicaux très différents et pourtant il
possède les mêmes racines mardi 10 mai
le collectif pour la semaine de la
mémoire de l'esclavagé
saint quentin en yvelines a organisé une
exposition dédiée à la musique noire au
temps de l'esclavagé
ils ont pu recueillir avec des
instruments ou de matériaux trouvés sur
place vous pourrez trier des styles des
jarres musicaux à partir de 6 heures
avec le mélange du
d'autre que d'inspiration d'auto musique
jean européenne ou
amérindienne 14 panneaux retracent
l'histoire de chaque genre musical on
apprend alors que la samba au brésil
puise ses racines en afrique et plus
précisément en angola et au congo une
exposition pour rappeler l'importance de
l' esclavage sur le monde et la musique
c'est un pan de l'histoire de l'humanité
le premier système mondialisé ce que ça
touche et
les trois continents donc il faut
partager simplement là pour pouvoir
construire un moment de rire ensemble
l'avenue évolutive l'exposition sera
agrémenté année après année d'autres
courants musicaux la traite négrière a
fait plus de 25 millions de victimes à
travers le monde